keith is with us in Concord New
Hampshire hey Keith how are you I'm
great Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world oh well
me and my wife are both in baby steps -
and we we figured it out today that it
will take a two years together that if
we stitch both of our cars and get a
couple of Junkers and it will take a
three years if we don't and I wanted to
run the numbers by you and see if you
thought it was worth it okay then you
say your bars and baby step - you mean
you're both working a debt snowball
together you're not working to debts
snowballs absolutely it's wide open I
guess we're in it together yet and I
guess you're understood what you were
saying okay how much you owe on cause
the cars one of them we owe 11,000 and
the other we owe 14,000 okay and what
are they worth the 11 what's it worth
9500 okay and what's the 14 worth 10
okay so about ten each on and what's
your household income 55 before taxes we
take home about 45 okay do you owe any
do you own anything else with a motor in
it yeah okay all right well our rule of
thumb is twofold one is can I be
debt-free within two years not counting
my house you're saying no so that kind
of makes me want to sell something and
my other rule of thumb is don't own even
if you're debt-free and even if you're
paying cash you should not have more
than half your annual income invested in
things that go down in value called cars
boats that's C dues and they're sisters
okay so you add up everything like that
you're not violating that one because
you're at 20 which is less than half of
55 right so you're not violating that
one the other one what other kinds of
debt have you got we have a $9,000
personal loan and 14,000 in credit card
that's it yeah okay
and so um 25 in one year and I think I
would cut my budget deeper and key
my favorite car of the two okay I'd meet
I don't halfway which of these two cars
is your fav is your all's favorite
between the two of you well I'd say her
does it have to be the favorite okay
yeah mama's car is the last one to be
sold that's Federal Rule all right
federal law okay so that's the 14th it
is okay then if we soldiers for ten we
go right now you have 45 thousand
dollars in debt total with a fifty five
thousand dollar income if you paid
twenty to five off a year for two years
you'd be debt-free in two years you
could make it but it would be very very
strenuous to barely make it if we sold
your car instead of having forty five we
have thirty five thousand dollars in
debt that's seventeen five a year for
two years in debt reduction making fifty
five you better be able to do that one
all right absolutely
you'd be debt-free in two years and keep
her car and then move up in car after
you get your you move up in car after
you get your emergency fund done yep I
don't they thank you I think that one
you see how I did that yeah absolutely
because I don't want the cars to be a
vote anchor that holds you down yours
are kind of on the border the good news
is we could split it here it wasn't like
one twenty thousand dollar car if we had
to make one big decision that car would
just be gone but in this case we could
split it between the two and you lose
your car but yeah but another the math
starts to be reasonable then can you
payout seventeen thousand five hundred
dollars in debt a year for two years
making fifty five I think you can hey I
think we can hear ya and that makes you
debt-free in two years and then you
start saving your emergency fund and you
save up to move up in your car so good
question thank you for joining us man
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]